she knew this one no  Debbie ocean convicted felon her brother  Danny ocean more convicted felon she was  present on the night of the incident oh  so oh you want to hit a jewelry store  not exactly a diamond mine yes it's  exactly right before what the met and  that would be hosting its annual ball  and we are going to rob it sixteen point  five million dollars in each of your  bank accounts five weeks from now that's  a lot they've got every inch of this  place covered this is most sophisticated  security in the world  [Music]  how long did it take you to figure all  this out five years eight months and 12  days why do you need to do this because  that's what I'm gonna okay everybody  let's get started here we go count me  down three two  came on  she said  [Music]  dear God that was exact you  Silvia's we prepare for this  [Music]  we will not be the prime suspects  wait wait wait everytime you have to  start from surprise wait what'd you do I  turn it on  [Music]  you